viking la sonde laboratoire à la
recherche de la vie sur mars
italie le premier jour du vote corse
les retombées d'aléria sur le tourisme
de lille cyclisme dit sybille valeureux
champion de france
tiercé combinaison gagnante 10 as 14
bonsoir la planète rouge va-t-elle livré
son secret vous le saurez demain
j'arrête là la plaisanterie tout de
suite car en fait l'expérience viking 1
c'est très sérieux
l'explication de mou depuis hier la
sonde américaine viking est en orbite
autour de mars si tout se passe bien
dans une quinzaine de jours les
responsables américains déclencheront
l'atterrissage sur mars d'un des
compartiments de longin et on pourra
alors peut être répondre à cette
question
la vie existe t-elle sur la planète la
terre est elle la seule planète du
système solaire sur laquelle la vie
existe
l'homme est il le seul être intelligent
de tout l'univers
les savants qui ont horreur de se poser
des questions sans essayer d'y répondre
ont décidé d'aller voir ailleurs si la
vie existait après avoir éliminé la lune
vénus et mercure
il se tourne aujourd'hui vers mars la
planète rouge depuis la découverte des
canaux de ce qui apparaît les
l'astronome italien de la fin du siècle
dernier les pour et les contres
s'affrontent sans répit mais avec les
anges interplanétaire moderne on sait
aujourd'hui que les petits hommes verts
n'existe pas par contre personne ne peut
dire si les changements de couleurs de
la planète mars ne sont dues au vent ou
si des saisons ils font croître les
plantes mystérieuse habitué au froid
glacial qui règne sur cette planète 10
degrés au maximum à midi à l'équateur au
manque d'eau et à l'atmosphère très
raréfier aujourd'hui ces questions vont
cesser d'être théorique l'homme vient de
mettre en orbite autour de mars
le premier des deux vikings parti l'été
dernier avec comme mission principale
voie si la vie existe sur la planète
rouge depuis tout à l'heure wiedeking
cherche un endroit où se poser on lui en
avait trouvé deux à partir des photos
anciennes
il a 15 jours pour vérifier si un au
moins de ces deux endroits convient puis
le 4 juillet alors qu'il sera à 15 cents
kilomètres d'altitude vikings enverra
vers le sol
un laboratoire d'analysés chimiques
physiques et surtout biologique
ce laboratoire sera protégé pendant la
descente par un bouclier thermique
largable dès que l'atmosphère martienne
ne permettra un parachute spécialement
étudiée s'ouvrira pour ralentir cette
descente car l'air de mars est 100 fois
moins dense que l'air de la terre et
donc le ralentissement sera moins fort
en fin de course ce sont des rétrofusées
classique qui permettront laboratoire de
vikings de se poser en douceur sur le
sol de mars
première opération bien sûr prendre des
photos puis les analyses commence avec
celle qui nous intéresse le plus la
recherche de la vie ce bras très long
pour éviter de ramasser des échantillons
de sol brûlé par les gaz chauds des
rétrofusées rapportera vers le
laboratoire des morceaux de mars qui
seront analysées si à l'intérieur de ces
morceaux se trouvent des habitants
martien aussi modeste soit-il insectes
bactéries ou simple cellule l'analyse
les détectera à coup sûr grâce à cet
appareil spécial mais ce soir nous n'en
sommes pas encore là vikings vient de
réussir sa première opération la mise en
orbite en prime comme pour justifier par
avance les 5 milliards de son prix il a
détecté un grand nuage de vapeur d'eau
et de la glace au fond de certains
cratères
déjà c'est un bon signe pour y trouver
la vie
depuis ce matin l'italie vote à
l'italienne c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas
eu de grande précipitation vers les
isoloirs les principaux leaders
politiques comme enrico berling werle
communiste ou aldo moro le démocrate
chrétien ont bien essayé de montrer
l'exemple
ils n'ont pas été beaucoup suit le
simple citoyen a préféré profiter du
soleil italien à la campagne ou à la
plage avant même de se rendre de prendre
le chemin du bureau les résultats de ces
élections si importante avant la nuit de
lundi à mardi puisque demain les
italiens vont encore voter jusqu'à 14
heures
en tout cas ce dimanche électoral s'est
déroulé le plus calmement du monde et
c'est à souligner puisque cette campagne
électorale a fait six morts sans compter
tous les attentats qui se sont produits
contre les sièges des partis politiques
ce référendum car il s'agit bien d'un
référendum pour ou contre la
participation des communistes au pouvoir
a mobilisé 40 millions d'électeurs je
dis bien mobilisés car on s'attend à une
participation électorale de l'ordre de
90 92 %
il ya une inconnue dans ces élections
comment vont voter les 5 million et demi
de jeunes qui ont entre 18 et 25 ans et
qui vont donc voter pour la première
fois d'après certains sondages la
majorité d'entre eux votre et à gauche
mais pas forcément pour le parti
communiste
mais pour nous la citation
l'italie c'est dramatique il faut
changer la direction du pays avec des
nouvelles perches ont poussée à gauche
également du côté des femmes semble-t-il
qui pourtant est tendance à voter pour
l'ordre établi mais il ne s'agit là que
d'intentions de vote et tout peut
changer
au moment de ce vote capital pour
l'avenir de l'italie est ce que pour
vous ces élections sont importantes
oui très importante parce que vraiment
c'est un moment où on aura un tournant
dans la vie de l'italie la seule
certitude que nous ayons pour le moment
c'est qu'il s'agit d'élections très
importante
après les élections de 48 sél et les
élections les plus importantes que les
pays et tu et le pays a besoin d'un
changement profond et de changer surtout
le parti qui a été jusqu'à présent
responsable de la politique du pays en
sont très importantes sont vitales pour
notre pays
pourquoi pourquoi c'est une décision
fils de changer le système pas ou pas
c'est pour façon très importante
c'est aussi votre opinion madame
absolument sinon je ne serais pas
déranger ou libon l'opération évacuation
par mer des étrangers organisée par les
américains s'est déroulée sans aucun
problème
tout s'est passé dans le calme en une
heure les marins américains en bras de
chemise sans armes ont embarqué les 300
étrangers qui voulaient partir de
paradoxe quand même malgré les consignes
à ses fermes de gerald ford peu
d'américains ont accepté cette
évacuation
d'autre part ce sont des palestiniens de
l'ol paie mitraillette en main qui
protégeait le départ d étranges d'un
moment à l'autre le premier ministre sud
africain doit arriver lui en allemagne
fédérale pour y rencontrer en
particulier enrique kissinger john buchs
teurs aura une mauvaise surprise en
débarquant à francfort car le ministère
ouest allemand des affaires étrangères
vient de publier un communiqué assez
sévères mettant en garde l'afrique du
sud contre la poursuite de sa politique
d'apartheid
c'est à dire la politique de ségrégation
raciale il ya quelques heures le conseil
de sécurité des nations unies avait déjà
condamné à l'unanimité
l'attitude de répressive du gouvernement
sud africain au cours des dernières
émeutes raciales
enfin deux jours avant la visite
officielle de valéry giscard d'estaing
en grande bretagne les journaux
britanniques de ce matin répétait à
l'unisson il y a encore des malentendus
entre paris et londres
monsieur giscard d'estaing de son côté a
précisé hier dans le times que les
relations entre la france et la grande
bretagne doivent ressembler à celle qui
existe entre paris et bonn il ya déjà au
moins un point commun entre james
callaghan le premier ministre
britannique et valéry giscard d'estaing
avant même le début de cette visite
ils ont été tous les deux ministres des
finances dans le passé je pense que les
relations que nous pouvons avoir entre
nous sont bien comprises à la fois par
la france l'angleterre et nous
accueillons président giscard dans le
but évident de parler de nos relations
bilatérales mais encore davantage de
définir ensemble notre ligne de conduite
sur les problèmes mondiaux puisque la
france et la grande-bretagne sont
pratiquement les seuls pays à avoir une
telle expérience des relations
internationales
quant à savoir si la france et la
grande-bretagne sont proches l'une de
l'autre ce n'est pas une question
politique mais avant tout une question
de personnes en france et en europe
votre image monsieur le premier ministre
n'est pas celle d'un européen convaincu
on estime même que la grande bretagne
actuellement ne joue pas avec assez de
conviction son nouveau rôle européen
êtes vous d'accord non absolument pas
retour en france avec la politique
après les remous qui ont secoué la
majorité ces derniers jours et avant la
reprise de la discussion sur les plus
values à l'assemblée nationale il semble
que ce week-end a été marqué par un
armistice dans les rangs de la majorité
hier à la convention nationale des
républicains indépendants jacques
dominati a cherché surtout à ne pas
faire de peine à lui dr aujourd'hui
monsieur yves guéna d'un côté monsieur
jacques chirac de l'autre ont demandé
une mobilisation contre l'opposition
reste maintenant à savoir s'il s'agit
vraiment d'un armistice ou d'un repli
tactique est bien plus de directeur fois
c'est à peu près ce qu'a dit monsieur
chirac après le chef de l'état aux
membres de la majorité
il reste qu'il y a toujours des grimaces
derrière ce paravent de la mobilisation
contre l'opposition
le oui enrobé de précaution de monsieur
dominati aux offres de recentrage faite
par monsieur lecanu et n'a pas calmé les
craintes de lutter
l'opération même
qik est sous anesthésie vise en fait à
rééquilibrer les forces au profit des
giscardiens c'est un peu la réédition de
ce qu'ont réalisé les socialistes au
détriment des communistes il est
maintenant certain que cette tentative a
bien l'aval du président giscard
d'estaing elle explique le raidissement
de l'ue dr acculé à démontrer sa force
la tâche de monsieur chirac qui a promis
à ses amis de la faire retrouver au
moins 160 sièges à l'assemblée n'en sera
pas facilitée
d'autant plus que les investitures
seront sûrement délivré par le président
de la république c'est à travers ces
données qu'il faut suivre les sursauts
de lui des airs pour sauvegarder un
acquis de près de 20 ans
en dehors de la convention nationale des
républiques indépendantes dont je vous
parlais il ya quelques minutes et du
conseil national des radicaux de gauche
à nantes il y avait ce week-end à paris
dans l'ancienne gare de la bastille le
deuxième rassemblement national de la
joc la jeunesse ouvrière chrétienne 5000
jeunes apprentis ont participé à cette
réunion
quand les jeunes ouvriers chrétiens se
rassemblent c'est d'abord une fête cette
année à l'ombre de la bastille pour ces
apprentis qui rentre dans la vie active
c'est aussi l'occasion de réfléchir sur
leurs arrières
par exemple malgré la reprise économique
tous ne sont pas sûres demain de trouver
du travail
c'est pourquoi les organisations
syndicales s'intéresse de près à ses
militants en herbe
pour l'instant il rejette à la pologne
gestion proposée par la cfdt et le
centralisme de la cgt mais georges séguy
edmond maire ont suivi personnellement
avec attention leurs travaux sur le plan
politique par d'ambiguïté les jeunes
travailleurs chrétiens ont réaffirmé
leur soutien à la gauche unie
edmond simeoni et ses coïnculpés
autonomistes corses connaîtront
probablement leur sort mardi
je vous rappelle que l'avocat général a
réclamé 5 ans de détention contre le
docteur 6 millions au total ce procès
aura donc duré plus de cinq semaines
cinq semaines pendant lesquelles on a
parlé presque tous les jours dans les
journaux à la radio sur antenne 2 non
seulement de ce procès des autonomistes
corses mais aussi de la situation dans
lui alors à quelques heures du verdict
on peut se demander si tous ces
événements finalement n'ont pas effrayé
les touristes
apparemment c'est simple vacances en
corse égale soleil mer ciel bleu mais
cette année le tableau et voit les camps
de nudistes mise à part les touristes
arrivent moins nombreux sur l'île
rien n'est perdu d'avancé mais les
bavarois où les rhénans ont été nombreux
à annuler leurs habituels réservation il
ya la saison mois de mars avril
s'annonçait de manière tout à fait
normal c'est à dire que au niveau de
l'hôtellerie en corse ont enregistré
beaucoup plus de monde que l'année
précédente et un chiffrement de cette
augmentation à 20 % vous plaît
malheureusement les bus mais la date du
procès est inconnue c'est-à-dire au 17
mai à partir de ce moment là en
enregistrer un arrêt brutal de toutes
les réservations et la saison débutant
on a constaté immédiatement qu'il y
avait des désaffections plus importante
que l'on chiffres pour le mois de mai
environ dans 30% deux premières raisons
les moyens de transport maritime ont
connu des difficultés matérielles le
personnel cgt de l'ex transat n'hésitons
pas à affirmer que ces bateaux sont
atteints par la limite d'âge
et puis les agences de voyages évite de
proposer les vacances en l'île de beauté
notamment les agences suisses allemandes
et hollandaises
enfin un exemple ce quotidien hollandais
inscrivant la corse c'est peu sûr et
c'est cher on ne dit pas non mais on dit
pas oui on dit pas où il faut il encore
dit vous savez encore c'est en ce moment
c'est pas tellement alors si vous voulez
on fait une petite que j'appelle
vraiment une petite guerre psychologique
d'ajaccio à bastia du sud au nord de la
corse il ya pourtant déjà beaucoup de
touristes français ou étrangers si
quelques-uns émettent des critiques
d'organisations sur les campings
notamment aucune inquiétude ne semble
avoir précédé le choix de ses congés
est-ce que vous avez une certaine
appréhension m'ont donné encore se
consoler c'est un mandat très mal parce
que je prenais bien et corse j'ai
beaucoup d'amis en cause vous saviez
qu'il y avait eu un certain nombre
d'événements l'été dernier puis des
attentats ça nous a pas fait peur en eau
parce qu'il ya des bombes à bruxelles et
à paris
tout est bon c'est normal
le grave ce sont les conséquences
économiques de cette diminution du
nombre des touristes dans le domaine de
l'agriculture où les exploitants de la
plaine orientale et coule sur place
pendant la saison l'essentiel de leur
production pour ce mois de juin la
mévente est importante
les prix des légumes des fruits sont
inférieurs de 50% à ceux de l'an passé
quant aux petits commerçants il constate
une baisse de clients et ne veulent pas
prendre de risque en stockant trop de
marchandises dans l' attente de jours
meilleurs
les années précédentes on avait prévu un
roulement de stoke 1-1 changements plus
importants pour le passé cette saison
que cette année on a complètement réduit
les stocks est également là changement
parce qu'on veut venir on veut voir
venir même si cette saison est mauvaise
et commerçants ne vont pas se retourner
contre eux je tenais absolument pas moi
mon avis non je pense qu'il ya toute une
manoeuvre pour que en fin de course ce
soit les autonomistes qui soit
responsable tout ça enfin lorsqu'un
français débarquent à bastia ou
injection et qui le voit sur les murs
écrit français en de corse
il a peut-être de bonnes raisons d'avoir
peur non moi je pense que c'est surtout
symbolique lorsqu'on voit sur mur ne
français hors de corse je pense pas
qu'on puisse faire de la littérature sur
un mur et expliquer tout un courant de
pensée en quatre coups de pinceau
français dehors ça veut simplement dire
gouvernement français essayer de prendre
un peu plus au sérieux les problèmes
course viendront viendront pas le
verdict du procès retiendra-t-il les
centaines de milliers de touristes sur
le continent et les 50000 plaisanciers
de 1975 sur la côte d'azur
cette fois ce n'est plus seulement
l'organisation du tourisme en corse qui
pose question mais bien le fait que
l'île est trop dépendante de cet apport
financier trop lié à une ressource
unique qu'elles ne contrôlent même pas
dans le championnat de france de
cyclisme professionnel sur route on
attendait esclassan le régional de
l'étape comme on dit ou même thévenet
finalement c'est le marseillais guy zibi
qui a gagné à montauban cet après midi
en battant au sprint le jeune alain
meslet dans quatre jours donc au départ
du tour de france d'ici billes portera
fièrement son nouveau maillot bleu blanc
rouge même s'il ne doit rester pendant
le tour qu'un équipier pour thévenet
quatre hommes sont partis mais laisse
siby romero et delépine en tête alain
mail c'est l'échappée décisive
derrière le peloton s'est cassé en
plusieurs morceaux
dans ce peloton je n'ai martin au vieux
laurent les voici vont tenter de revenir
sur les fuyards mais c'est trop tard en
tête il va en rester 2 le marseillais
cybit et le mayennais alain meslet siby
maillot blanc romero et delépine ont dû
laisser fuir leurs compagnes mais elle
est en forme il vient le prouver au midi
libre
mais si biya du métier il est moins sec
dans ses relais se réserve pour le spray
et il va l'emporter ce qui s'y dit 28
ans un équipier qui se voient
récompensés
ça n'est pas un grand champion il le
sait c'est pourquoi dans quatre jours
départ du tour il redeviendra un anonyme
au service de thévenet
l'histoire se répète l'an dernier ovion
son coéquipier vêtus de tricolores
s'étaient mises au service du même
thévenet le cyclisme est parfois ingrat
et pour ceux ci bigand garçon a peiné
tram et bon camarade et discret qui est
double ce soir de caresser la gloire
a auteuil aujourd'hui trois grandes
épreuves le tiercé d'abord dont le prix
chaque en sort une course de haies de
3500 m et puis deux épreuves en forme de
marathon
d'abord la grande course de haies des 4
ans gagné par le favori beau dad
et puis enfin le grand steeple chase
public des grands jours cet après midi à
auteuil avec comme épreuve principale
grand steeple-chase de paris véritable
marathon long de 6500 mètres après le
saut de la rivière du 8 que franchit en
tête de série devant penny cuit piot
mares casaque bleue toque bleue le
peloton est encore regrouper les
véritables difficultés commencent avec
le talus penny quick et deux séries sont
tous deux au commandement et mènent un
train rapide alors que le poteau est
encore très loin le grand steeple-chase
de paris qui réunit chaque année l'élite
des chevaux de 5 ans et plus wyatt au
départ un grand favori néerlandais qui
avait triomphé dans cette même épreuve
en 75 qui remettait donc sa couronne en
jeu avant de franchir le rail ditch
obstacles plus redoutés d'auteuil
penny cuit avec un léger avantage sur
pied au marais si royal exil quant au
favori
il ne s'était pas encore manifesté à
1000 mètres de l'arrivée
le sprint est déjà lancé pierre marès
prend davantage en franchissant le
pendjab mont-royal exil penny quick et
irlandais qui commence à se rapprocher
une magnifique lutte va s'engager entre
l'outsider pierre mairesse est le favori
hollandais c'est dans les 200 derniers
mètres irlandais se donne à fond mais
les 6500 mètres pèse lourd il ne pouvait
jamais rejoindre camarès et ce dernier
triompher en grand champion
quand on prie chaque en dessous tiercé
long de 3600 mètres il a été dominé par
deux chevaux de qualité
art ou cno et cholet c'est ce dernier
qui assure et longtemps le commandement
ne vont pas en bleu et double majeur
dans la ligne droite chaud et l'air
kazakh blanche augmentait son avance
derrière lui une bonne quinzaine de
chevaux avaient encore leurs chances
c'est sur le plaquent art tous nos plats
c'est un effort spectaculaire et prenait
2 longueurs à chaud et l'air
quand béraud lui était bon troisième le
tiercé 10 1 14
non
on
cinéma maintenant comme chaque dimanche
soir avec la chronique de françois
château il est bien des pc le transforme
en éclats de rire les chantres qui
oblige le monde à se gratter
prenez par exemple un film que l'on peut
voir en ce moment silence on tourne
de roger kodjo l'hérault en sont très
sympathiques ce sont des garçons et des
filles qui n'ont qu'une envie montée
l'organisation hélas l'excès de leurs
dettes les entraîne dans une direction
qui les éloigne de cette question que se
posait justement le fait de musset à
quoi rêvent les jeunes filles
en un mot comme en cent pour s'en sortir
ils tournent un porno bien on ne demande
pas mieux que de les voir échapper à
leur triste destin hélas très vite au
bout d'un moment nos troubadours du hard
sont dépassés par leur propre entreprise
ils ont bon nous affirmer avec un joli
mouvement de menton et un mouvement un
peu moins jolie du reste de leur
personne que s'ils font exactement la
même chose que monsieur bénazéraf ils
sont contre leur film se met à l'unisson
des reins de leur interprète
le plus remarquable en est la chute
c'était fatal
on peut si j'ose dire l'apprendre par
tous les bouts la pornographie ce n'est
pas drôle
silence on tourne d'autre part et le
constat d'un autre drame celui de
quantité de jeunes cinéastes dont fait
partie justement roger cojo le synass
qui essaye depuis les années de
s'affirmer de dire qu'ils ont quelque
chose à prouver qu'ils ont du talent
mais qui ayant échoué par les moyens les
plus nobles croit désormais qu'ils vont
y parvenir en se servant des plus bas
dans on aura tout vu
georges lautner et son brillant
scénariste francis veber sont plus
honnêtes
eux aussi ils ont imaginé un garçon qui
est obligé pour faire son premier film
le dépouiller le vaudeville de son
accessoire essentiel le caleçon mais ici
on sent quelque chose de différent
on comprend la détresse d'un monde qui
est en train de perdre son art de vivre
on voit des espérances brisé on comprend
qu'une profession est menacée de mort on
assiste à la
l'inconscience à la veulerie de certains
producteurs qui la main sur le coeur
nous affirme que pour remplir une salle
aujourd'hui il faut employer des procédé
ignoble et il ajoute ces producteurs que
ce n'est pas leur faute
comment pourrait il faire autrement
c'est finalement le public qui décide le
public a toujours raison ses désirs sont
des ordres et s'il veut aujourd'hui
qu'on lui crache au visage
on ne peut pas sans lui manquer des gars
plus refusé l'aumône d'un crash a
brillamment animé par pierre richard par
miu miu par l'incomparable jean pierre
marielle
plusieurs scènes sont tout à fait dignes
d'éloges je pense en particulier à
celles où une jeune comédienne doit
réciter entièrement nue label délicate
tirade d'agnès dans l'école des femmes à
celle aussi où un des comédiens
spécialisé à comédiens mal se retrouvent
enfin heureux et purifier dans un lit
avec une dame va être obligé de payer de
sa personne mais surtout est ce là j'ai
l'impression que les prédécesseurs de
georges lautner de francis veber ne
l'avait même pas flairé pourtant ça sent
assez fort on aura tout vu
nous rappelle que si l'on veut monter
une production pornographique ya
toujours moyen de trouver de l'argent
y compris chez les gens qui sont
aujourd'hui le plus suppose est plus
respectables plus honorable le bénéfice
en effet peut atteindre 1000 %
alors soudain devant ce film qui fait
rire on ne rit plus et c'est très bien
ainsi
au commencement de cette chronique j'ai
cité al fath 2016 c'est avec lui que je
voudrais conclure car elle est de lui
aussi cette petite phrase on dit que
l'humanité marche
c'est bien possible mais dans quoi la
météo maintenant pour demain voici le
bulletin qui nous a transmis la
météorologie nationale les nuages
resteront passagèrement abondants au
nord de la loire et de petites pluies
éparses seront possibles près de la
manche et dans le nord
ailleurs le temps restera chaud et
souvent ensoleillé malgré une tendance
orageuse près des pyrénées
je vous souhaite une très belle soirée
sur antenne 2 si vous avez pris le
journal en cours voici un rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité
aujourd'hui vikings le laboratoire sand
américains recherchent la vie sur mars
italie on vote demain jusqu'à 14 heures
cyclisme
guy sybille nouveau champion de france
tercer le dise le 1 le 14
vers 23 heures la dernière édition du
journal
à